If you have as many dogs as I do,
you're gonna need one of these.
I have so many dogs in my house,
and you wouldn't even know if it doesn't smell like dog. Sit,
sit, sit.
Shelby,
we run this 24 7.
This is an air purifier, and it keeps our air clean.
We vacuum daily.
And then with this,
gathering all the hair and dander in the air,
the house smells sweet.
Let's check out how dirty the filter is.
All I need to do is slide,
turn this around, and we'll see how much dandered.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my god. Look at that.
That is how much dog hair and dander this thing has been picking up.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, this will be all the smell would be. Is right here in the filter.
Can you believe this is what we'd be breathing in
if we wasn't for this filter?
There are several settings to choose from, and a night mode.
And there's also a timer.
Oh! This is available on TikTok Shop
for only eighty one dollars and eighty one cents.
Is on sale right now as part of this TikTok Spring Sale.
Get it right now before the sale ends.
Shelby! Shelby!